alors la cavalerie arrive les renforts
ne sont pas très loin la vaccination
commence mais tranquillement faut le
dire la semaine prochaine au canada
josée legault chantal hébert christian
dufour bonsoir on se voit en cela je
vais entendre monsieur trudeau et le
général major général d'ubs et fortin et
je sais j'en ai nommé aujourd'hui fortin
sur cette nouvelle d'un terroir ordures
la livraison des doses et la vaccination
se passera extrêmement rapidement donc
les premiers canadiens vont se faire
vacciner
la semaine prochaine si on à
l'approbation de santé canada cette
semaine et c'est un ciment rapide
un jour ou deux pour passer à travers
les étapes de manutention déballage dg
le produit et puis décanter et puis le
mixage c'est relativement court les
professionnels de la santé
deux cent cinquante mille doses d'ici la
fin décembre on a besoin de deux doses
de ce vaccin là vous savez maintenant
néanmoins j'osais c'est une bonne
nouvelle ça commence et c'est sûr que
c'est une bonne nouvelle c'est la
fameuse lumière au bout du tunnel et on
commence enfin à l'avoir peu sauf que
désolé pour le souk
sauf que en effet c'est c'est pas c'est
pas énormément de doses pour le mois de
décembre ça c'est clair et on voit que
il ya eu eu de la pression petit trou
d'eau avaient été très critiqués parce
que c'est à peu près 6 parler seulement
de commencer premier trimestre 2021
mais là 'l'annonce la grande bretagne
qu'ils allaient commencer dès demain à
vacciner ses citoyens les états unis
très bientôt
c'est clair que ça a exercé une pression
pour que au moins le processus débute
plus rapide est ce que chantal ya une
surprise
dans quelle mesure la juge lisa sion
aujourd'hui c'est une surprise
ou parce qu'on nous avait préparé à la
possibilité que ça ne commence qu'après
le 1er janvier surprise ou pas la
surprise c'est que le gouvernement
trudeau qui avait plutôt l'habitude de
première beaucoup et de délivrer peu de
livres et peu à l'air d'avoir renversé
sa façon d'agir pour les vaccins c'est à
dire deux premières peut et de livrer un
peu plus alors ça changera pas le monde
c'est néanmoins une répétition générale
certainement utile pour des forces
armées pour les provinces de voir
comment on fonctionne pour déployer
parce que c'est une chose de recevoir
des livraisons c'en est une autre des
administrés de façon cohérente on
s'embarque quelque part pauvre monsieur
trudeau je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est
une annonce politique importante
vis-à-vis l'opposition on n'échappe pas
l'hiver
néanmoins je pense que ça c'est l' autre
chose que des gouvernements à celle de
10 aujourd'hui
oui c'est une bonne nouvelle il n'y
avait pas de vaccin et en neuf mois
mais ça veut pas dire qu'on passera pas
un hiver difficile
oui parce qu'on laisse un jeu du bain
qu'on va entendre plus tard au québec
qui est extrêmement inquiet parce que
dans les hôpitaux on commence
on recommence à faire du délestage de
manière importante
on rapporte des opérations report des
rendez-vous et christian du four
oui mais je reviens sur les vaccins qui
ont 6 ans parce que vous disiez la
semaine dernière vous étiez extrêmement
déçu qu'on commence pont canada à peu
près en même temps que les autres
êtes vous un peu moins déçu il faut être
positif
sauf que on voit que le gouvernement
était beaucoup sur la défensive
l'opposition conservatrice avait
beaucoup de pression
de même que l'opinion publique dont qui
ont réagi ce que j'ai retenu en fait de
ce que dit monsieur trudeau aujourd'hui
c'est dès la semaine prochaine dès la
semaine prochaine dès la semaine
prochaine on va avoir des images de
canadiens qui dès la semaine prochaine
si c'est approuver vont se faire
vacciner mais bien franchement quand on
regarde le nombre de vaccins 250000
vaccin c'est une goutte dans un océan
c'est difficile de pas pensé je m'excuse
d'être négative que c'est peut-être
l'opération de poudre aux yeux l'avenir
de girolles et parlons en effet pervers
là dedans parce qu'on sait qu'à partir
du moment où on diffuse le fait que les
gens commencent à être vaccinés est en
danger que les gens relâcher leur
vigilance qu'on observe - les consignes
donc une bonne nouvelle pour être
heureux mais on est dans l'image c'était
bien important qu'aujourd'hui le
gouvernement annonce qu'on va voir des
images de qualité qui se font vacciner
250 millions franchement patrice on en a
commandé au me dit 70 millions mais a
semblé 0 parce que on préparer la
population à 0 à l'aja 2 149 mille doses
de plus que ce qu'on avait quand même
dialogue on excède un peu les attend
qu'on avait mis mise très bas
oui chantal un petit mot là dessus
selon moi l'opposition conservatrice et
pièges et yann même parce que c'est quoi
la fera tout ce qui est excessif est
insignifiant à à force de dire le canada
est encore aujourd'hui le très mauvaise
nouvelle
triste journée mais à force de dire le
canada va être le dernier pays sur la
planète mais évidemment on s'est eu
tellement à l'extérieur et on se situe
là bas tellement beau que justin trudeau
avec 2 300 mille doses en décembre
symboliquement réussi à
apprendre à peu près toutes les manches
et cela dit c'est un fait qu'il faut
commencer quelque part et c'est mieux de
commencer en décembre et de tester du
système que de paul de tester on verra à
l'usure mais selon moi l'opposition
conservatrice s'est mis dans une
position difficile avec ses prédictions
josé à tour je n'en sais vraiment
d'aller dans le détail
bon évidemment ça peut changer au cours
des prochaines semaines on se le
souhaite vraiment mais si on regarde un
petit peu ce qui doit se donner au
québec d'ici le 4 janvier le ministre du
bio parler de 22000 à 28000 personnes
qui pourraient être vaccinées bon
peut-être tentons port parler de l'ordre
des priorités mais c'est pas non plus
beaucoup et quand on pense que cela
n'allait ch et celle d il ya quarante
mille résidents c'est pas comment ça
commence très bien
et moi je pense que sur le plein pour
lyon vient d'avant le vrai problème il
pourrait y pour être ce printemps si ça
ne va pas plus vite que très bientôt
rentrer les chefs de l'alberta qui
viennent de tomber une seconde 2735 cas
de plus donc ça continue la flèche
montrent de façon assez important d'un
alberto ruy la population plus jeune
sera pas long que ça j'ai presque fini
et 16 supplémentaires en alberta donc
voilà ça ça continue à être préoccupante
la situation là-bas aussi dans les
hôpitaux
il s'approche du nombre
d'hospitalisations du québec avec une
population beaucoup moins douée en tout
respect pour chantal moi je partage pas
bien franchement son opinion sur le
pouce en conservatrice à ottawa l'avenir
le dira mais moi je pense qu'ils y ont
scoré y ont bien fait franchement je
trouve que les gens sont pas très
exigeant
le côté poudre aux yeux moi j'y crois je
crois que 250 milles vaccin franchement
et il n'y a rien qui nous assure que ça
va causer
il faut être positif soyez vous même
christian je veux saisir ces cas moi ça
me irrité de voir juste un cadeau qui
est un maître de l'image aujourd'hui
banni
l'image on va entendre monsieur trudeau
et monsieur dubé de cette fois c'est le
vrai monsieur dubé sur comment ça va
être distribué aux provinces
alors ça sera effectivement au prorata
on écoute les deux lyon revient la
distribution de vaccins sera fait par
capita à travers le pays pour chaque
province les provinces eux vont
fonctionner à l'intérieur du cadre qui a
été établi par rapport aux populations
prioritaires mais il faut se souvenir
aussi que on est qu'au tout début d'un
processus de distribution qui va voir
des millions de vaccins distribués aux
canadiens dans les mois à venir
la première chose que je veux souligner
c'est que le québec est prêt à commencer
à vacciner dès que nous recevrons les
premières dont nous avons déjà identifié
au cours des derniers jours avec fraser
20 sites de vaccination au québec on a
déjà vacciné plus de 1.1 million de
personnes contre la grippe
1.1 million personnes vaccinées en un
mois ça démontre que nous sommes
capables de prendre du volume
vous en avez parlé rapidement vous
donner l'ordre de vaccination qui est à
peu près le même partout sur la planète
réside à un siège c'est le dire on va
voir le tableau
le sait les chiffres pour le québec
comme il y en a 40 mille des
travailleurs du réseau de la santé
services sociaux 325 mille personnes
vivent rpa les résidentes personnes
âgées 136000 quatrièmement les résidents
dans les communautés isolées éloignées
on espère que ce sera le vaccin de
modern à ce moment là qui est moins
difficile à faire voyager et autres
tableaux et lance une cascade
évidemment on aura compris cinquièmement
les personnes âgées de 80 ans et plus 70
ans 19 ans 69 ans et à tout dernier le
premier tableau on pense arriver d'ici
la fin mars deuxième tableau le havre
prendre certainement plusieurs mois
alors voilà pour les données précises
vous disiez christian les conservateurs
ont je reprends l'expression scorer
chantal vous pensez vous que ils ont
exagéré sur la question du vaccin calif
il faut presque il souhaite que ça aille
mal parce que si ça va bien ils vont se
discréditer je ne crois pas vraiment que
monsieur autour de ça soit chez lui en
souhaitant que ça aille mal mais même
déconseillé de killer suggéré vendredi
de se lancer sur d'autres secteurs que
les critiques de la gestion de la
pandémie parce que il ne score pas la
tuer je vous donne un exemple parce que
pour compter des points il faut quand
même que ça se mesure quelque part
monsieur autour depuis 100 jours un peu
plus maintenant a pas fait bouger d'un
nid auteur remarquable l'éguille des
sondages sur les vaccins une partie de
son problème d'abord c'est pour
l'instant les canadiens sont moins
pressés que lui c'est à dire et je pense
c'est votre sondage qui ne montrait
qu'ils sont prêts quand même à donner la
chance au coureur dans un premier temps
ce qui est logique parce que c'est
justin trudeau son opération de vaccins
je casse la figure au cours des trois
prochains mois
on va du savoir il va payer un prix pour
ça c'est pas nécessaire d'écrire le
script avant parce que le script bash
écrire toute chose mais le problème de
monsieur o'toole c'est que pendant ce
temps l'oeil est pas en train de donner
à son parti
d'autres sujets que les critiques du
gouvernement et très franchement avait
promis de se présenter comme un
gouvernement en attente
je vous demande 700 jours qu'il est là
dit moi c'est quoi la différence entre
et renault toul et end chez eux dans ce
que vous avez entendu ce que vous pouvez
prendre le nom d'un rocher le domaine
partout où il ya des papiers sur renault
tout lé depuis deux mois
si vous pouvez pas ça voudrait dire qui
a fait sa marque et sur 100 jours mais
je vous mets au défi de trouver comment
joseph et il a pris du temps mais
aujourd'hui il finalement il le fait il
s'est distancé de la pétition direction
sur député qui parle d'une
expérimentation humaine pour ce que la
vaccination allait y est il y en a comme
plein son assiette ou des bus avait bien
commencé on al'impression peut-être que
c'est plus difficile ça c'est derek
selon ce qu'on voit avec sa pétition sur
les combats contre eux où ils très
critique envers la vaccination jose mais
parce qu'on y aussi beaucoup d'alliés
dans l'image on parle beaucoup de
l'image donc cette rue comme m6 ou tout
le système beaucoup l'image au début
bilek plus sympathique souriant
prouvy ses bancs etc mais il le parti
qu'il a quand même et il un parti
politique ou la droite dure la vérité de
l'alliance canadienne est encore très
présent donc ça c'est ça fait partie de
partie de son assiette et moi je pense
que pour ce qu'il ya autour
je pense qu'il faut attendre il faut
attendre la campagne électorale pour
voir un petit plus il va finalement se
révéler ou pau mais patrice est ce que
vous me permettez d'ouvrir une parade
dans les yeux je vous parle sur merci
sur l'ordre de priorité tout à l'heure
on est tous le monde mentionne leur à un
peu ce sont des rats alors à eux se sont
laissé des résidents à ch et celle des
mais il ya aussi les résidents en
ressources intermédiaires et en
ressources de type familial et fameuse
aiguière tfc 16000 personnes au québec
ce sont principalement des personnes
handicapés intellectuellement ou
physique donc qu'ils cessent ça fait
quand même c'est tout ça va devoir
commander pas mal plus de doses qu'est
ce que monsieur trudeau annoncé oui les
gens qui aiment les chiffres voit le
tableau l'ordre de priorité il ya ici
lâche 1 du mois de mars
on annonce 6 millions de doses de phase
2 au canada
ça c'est trois millions de personnes
prenez deux sabres a 2 ou alors on
espère que moderna va arriver assez vite
plus facile à donner et d'autres
christian de sorte que pour faire
martyrs
on vient l'opposition nommé pour faire
mentir morale sachs est très très là on
espère que ça va s'accélérer de manière
exponentielle
pourquoi je te vois tu fais ce que je te
parle
oui ça vous ouais ok pourquoi je trouve
que en tout respect pour chantal encore
monsieur tout ce qu'on avait c'est que
je pense qu'aujourd'hui je t'ai toujours
beaucoup réagit aux pressions
conservatrices et les pressions
conservatrices là sur le fait que le
canada on est en retard sur les vaccins
s'apprête inutile ça a produit des
effets c'est vrai que jusqu'à présent
erin o'toole en fait on pour faire
bouger beaucoup les autres les chiffres
mais c'était très difficile de le faire
parce que c'est un concept mais c'est un
contexte proprement exceptionnels je
pense que ce soit au québec ou au canada
dans la plupart des sociétés eurent à
lima autour d'eux
il a même surtout la fête exceptionnelle
je pense pas que ça a été très efficace
je trouve que sont son premier mouche
qui est important je trouve c'est à
l'égard des bacs si je pense que ça
s'est reproduit un défendre le vus
aujourd'hui et je crois que ce qui
pourrait l'aider on va lever c'est quand
on s'enfonce dans la crise
c'est plus en plus difficile le moral
des gens est atteint il ya des gens qui
veulent encore plus de mesures de
confinement on peut pas eu d'histoire
comme abandonner le pilote public change
que le monde ordinaire ce talent et à
son âge pour faire une auto il sera
mieux placée est un point sauf qu'ils
leur issue c'est qu'au québec son image
me semble nettement plus positif que
celui de monsieur de son prédécesseur
donc l'avenir le dira évidemment on
parle pour parler mais je pense que pour
monsieur o'toole c'est peut-être
maintenant que ça commence parce qu'on
entre dans une autre phase de la
pandémie ou le gouvernement n'aura pas
droit à l'erreur
et puis lorsqu'on dit les prochains mois
je comprends que toulouse mais ce sont
des belles paroles moi j'attends là
qu'on arrive à l'aider réellement
oui bien sûr vous revenez avec ça oui
c'est moi je n'ai jamais demandé
l'impossible j'ai demandé au père d'un
ami
puis deux jeunes qui font des choses mon
épaule est juste un moulin tout le monde
qui est au pouvoir qui profite de la
pandémie
c'est pas exact et il suffit de regarder
ce qui est en train d'arriver à monsieur
canet et a reçu par d'esker deux amis de
monsieur au tour en passant dont la
majorité des administrés pense qu'ils
font pop
de la belle ouvrage donc ça ne va pas
bien pour toi est-ce que c'est terminé
mais bon on est positive leur salut
[Rires]